(audience cheering)
- Everywhere we go, I'm like...
(audience cheers and applauds)
It's crazy.
(Kelly chuckles)
Well, I meant, calm down.
They're literally, like I said
your name a minute ago and they scared me.
I was like, that's never
happened in three seasons.
Well, I mentioned you won a Grammy
for your work with your
girlfriend, Taylor Swift.
(audience cheers)
So that's amazing.
- Okay. Thank you.
- But I love that you,
I find it really cool -
you did it under a pseudonym.
You - it wasn't your name.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, why did you choose to do that?
- Well, we chose to do it so that people,
first and foremost, would
listen to the music first
before dissecting the fact
that we did it together.
- (Kelly) Yeah!
- But yeah,
I did it under a name, William Bowery.
- Yeah.
- Which sounds like-
- Very fancy.
- Yeah.
- Sounds like a kind of
Agatha Christie character,
- Yeah.
- I should be wearing
a monocle with a big mustache.
(Kelly laughs)
But, yeah, it was a combination of
William, my great grandfather,
who I never actually met,
was a composer. He wrote a lot of
classical music,
- Oh!
and he wrote a lot of film scores.
And then Bowery is the area
in New York that I spent
a lot of time in when I
first went over there. So.
- I love that.
- Stick them together.
- That's how you...okay.
But wait, I actually love this story
cause you starred with
Steve Martin, who I love,
and you starred in a movie with him.
It was your first movie, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
So, I love that he thought
that your accent was fake
because this film, was
it was it based in Texas?
Is that what I?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay. So you had an American accent.
- I did.
- And you just kept that
all the time.
- I guess I kept it around him. Yeah.
- And then he thought
you were like BSing him
and like, "Why are you speaking
with British accent to me?"
- I guess. I mean, I don't
remember keeping it all the time,
but I did sometimes.
And I guess I did when I was around
Steve Martin for some reason.
And then, yeah, it got to like, press day
a few months, you know, like a year later.
And he was like, "Ah, you're English."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- I mean, job well done.
Like, he had no idea. That's amazing.
You're really good at accents.
- It went down well.
- I just love that, like a
year later after filming,
"Wait, you're British?"
- I know.
- Like, it's a lot of
missed moments there,
but anyway.
- It's fine.
Well, speaking of
moments, so your new show
is called "Conversations with Friends".
So you do fewer fake accents,
but more intimate scenes.
Are those awkward for you
or do you just kind of
go to another place?
- I mean, they're like, they're obviously
a weird, funny strange part of the job.
- I feel like it's yeah.
I would be awkward.
- But they're not, I mean they
nowadays, when you do them
they often have like they're called
- the coach or something.
- Intimacy coordinator.
- Yeah.
- So they come in and
they're the ones who have
like the embarrassing,
not embarrassing job, they do
like a really important job.
But they're the ones who
roll around on the floor
making funny noises and showing
you what shapes to make.
- Oh my gosh.
- And then you just kind of copy them.
That's I'm bending, yeah.
I'm bending it slightly, but
- That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Sounds like
a fun party, but anyway
but so the show
- They want you to have fun.
I'm like, it sounds like
fun, like I would have -
So the, the show is
based on a novel, right?
- Yeah. The show is based
on a book by Sally Rooney.
- Yeah.
- Who also wrote
"Normal People".
And she's an Irish au-author.
And yes, it's a brilliant, brilliant book.
I read it when it came
out and it's directed by
a brilliant Irish filmmaker
called Lenny Abrahamson.
And yeah, it was a joy to be a part of.
- What's the overall just cuz
even from that, it looks like
you might be doing something
you shouldn't be doing.
Oh! Yep! (laughing) I was like -
- I mean um, the gist of it is,
it basically - it's really
like like a coming of age story
for this girl who you saw briefly there
called Frances who's this 21
year old student in Dublin
and she and her best friend
become kind of entangled
with an older couple and Frances and Nick,
who I play, have an affair
and it all gets kind
of messy and complicated.
And I suppose at its heart, it's asking
can you love more than one person at once?
And can you find love and
happiness and intimacy outside
of constructs of
conventional relationships
like friendships, families, marriages,
and uh -
- Interesting.
Yeah. It's kind of, it's like a,
a modern kind of love story.
- Yeah.
- Kind of heavy but a really cool subject
that you don't really
see talked about a lot.
- Yeah yeah.
All right. Well thank you for coming by.
- Thanks for having me.
- Yeah."Conversations
with Friends" now on Hulu.